depuis le mois de censé faire depuis
l'âge de 4 mois ils ont pas fait un pas
pour voir si je suis si je suis encore
vivant ou si je suis mort
les gens d'ici ce ne sont pas seulement
des gens qui sont contents de leur vie
ce sont aussi des gens qui ont toutes
les raisons d'en être mécontents nous en
avons rencontré dans le Bordelais où
nous sommes cette semaine et nous
n'avons pas voulu les éviter handicapé
mentaux ils accusent leur famille avec
virulence et par ricochet la société
elle-même à villembis ancien château
viticole c'est handicapé vivent et
travaillent presque normalement on les
aide à oublier leur passé mais dans les
propos que vous allez entendre il y aura
de la haine et de la violence il y aura
beaucoup de tendresse aussi
tu es toujours
à de Jean-Marie comment
[Musique]
Jean-Marie c'est ton copain alors
le grand chéri
[Musique]
vous vivez ensemble ici on vit ensemble
à partir de l'heure quoi l'heure qu'on
va se coucher
c'est tout Thomas à part que le reste on
peut vivre en couple qu'on peut vivre
ensemble tous les deux mais à part quand
tu arrives lors
[Musique]
c'est pareil
on se retrouve tous les trois et si on
achète
où est-ce que tu vas le dimanche moi je
vais chez moi
je m'attends autour de lui
[Musique]
et pourquoi tu travailles pas avec eux
je suis pas son fils je suis un neveu
c'était quand même quelqu'un de la
famille ils veulent pas
[Musique]
travailler
chez eux
[Musique]
ils veulent pas
et pourquoi
[Musique]
mon patron
ça t'a plu
ça t'embête de pas vouloir travailler
chez eux merci les filles
je vais
[Musique]
8 ans
tu l'as vu mort alors
troisième étage merci
ma mère
[Musique]
j'avais 12 ans
j'ai descendais parce que c'était obligé
de descendre c'est pour faire monter à
voiture j'étais là j'attendais que la
voiture
dans sa voiture non ça va être dur
tu as rien pu faire
au moment je dis mais c'était trop tard
elle voulait me laisser à la clinique
depuis le grain et ma grand-mère n'a pas
voulu c'est elle qui m'a élevé depuis ma
naissance jusqu'à 18 ans
jusqu'à la majorité
parce qu'elle a été trop dégueulasse
pour vous alors
[Musique]
je la connais un peu mais pas de vue
parce que ma grand-mère me l'a dit mais
elle a pas fait trop de belles choses
c'est quoi
et puis
c'est comme ça qu'elle m'a eu
avec un copain de Marie qu'elle avait
déjà
[Musique]
c'est ma grand-mère qui me l'a dit
je suis né à Blaye mon père et ma mère
sont une blague aussi mon père s'appelle
bien il s'appelle Jacques boulanger ma
mère le nom de jeune fille
blague c'est dans le Médoc ou pas
et ce qui est plus important c'est que
je connais je connais mon père et ma
mère et la date de naissance et tout où
ils sont nés mais pour elles ont été
incapables de me retrouver parce que les
avis que je vais donc quand je demande à
mon gardien
parce que j'ai demandé à savoir si je
pouvais aller les voir ou alors savoir
qui vient de me voir eux-mêmes ils ont
fait aucun pas aucun pas je demande j'ai
bien dit aucun pas c'est qu'ils ont pas
venu me voir depuis l'âge depuis sa
maman
depuis le monde
ils ont pas fait un pas pour voir si je
suis si je suis encore vivant ou si je
suis mort mais toi tu as leur adresse
[Musique]
je ferai tout ce que je veux mais comme
je suis seul de la famille je suis seul
et bien mais je ferai rien sur le jeu
ils ont bien voulu faire ça ils m'ont
abandonné mais moi je ferai pareil c'est
végétal
[Musique]
même quand ils seront vieux
alors là je laisse tomber ils peuvent
faire ce qu'ils veulent moi ils ont fait
pareil à moi moi je fais pareil genre
c'est très en colère contre
ils ont pas cherché à me retrouver quand
on se mariera il faut pas compter qu'on
les invite mais moi j'inviterai personne
de ma famille
que ma mère c'est pareil il faut pas
qu'ils y comptent comment ça se passe
avec les gens des villages autour d'ici
sans ils sont gentils avec toi
les commerçants ils cherchent jamais à
vous voler jamais
toujours dans le même commerce toujours
et même mon bar au bar on se méfie parce
que on sait ça fait voler
c'était déjà fait voler
[Musique]
et je regarde
je regarde je regarde le ticket je
regroupe c'est pas ça je crée un peu et
puis on me redonne juste
de crier quand même je suis obligé de
créer un peu
[Musique]